culpable de cinco de los seis cargos
incluido el de tráfico sexual de menores
gillane maxwell que cumplió 60 años el
día de navidad podría pasar el resto de
su vida tras las rejas con una sentencia
de 40 años por el cargo más grave es un
desenlace esperado por mucho tiempo por
las mujeres que la responsabilizan de
haberlas atraído siendo aún menores de
edad para que fueran abusadas
sexualmente por jeffrey epstein
es maravilloso poder responsabilizar a
alguien por lo que les ha sucedido y da
un cierto sentido de justicia en la
sociedad aun casters sabes cuando las
personas no rinden cuentas las víctimas
sienten que no tienen voz o life of the
ways la defensa sin embargo argumenta
que maxwell solamente fue acusada porque
las víctimas fueron privadas de su
principal abusador jeffrey epstein quien
se suicidó mientras esperaba su juicio
en 2019
en sense creemos firmemente en la
inocencia de gillane obviamente estamos
muy decepcionados con el veredicto ya
hemos empezado a trabajar en la
apelación y estamos seguros de que
saldrá adelante después de crecer en la
alta sociedad británica como hija de uno
de los magnates de medios más
importantes acogió fácilmente en la vida
lujosa que el financiero estadounidense
le proporcionó con registros bancarios
que demuestran que su expareja le
transfirió hasta 30 millones de dólares
a sus cuentas y para preservar su
posición de favorita estaba incluso
dispuesta a satisfacer sus demandas más
sórdidas con una fecha de sentencia para
maxwell aún por anunciarse la atención
se gira hacia quien más podría haberse
implicado en el escándalo de epstein
especialmente sus invitados donde están
famosos empresarios ex presidentes de
eeuu y la realeza británica